first on CBS this morning Stacey Abrams
joins us from Atlanta to announce the
new initiative that she's working on
it's helping people hit the hardest by
the coronavirus Abrams is a founder of
fair fight 2020 and as you know was a
2018 Democratic candidate for governor
of Georgia good morning to you Stacey
Abrams always good to see you I want to
talk about your initiative in just a
second but first I want to start with
your governor's decision to reopen I
want to get your reaction to that you
have called it dangerously incompetent
what concerns you Georgia is a state
that has one of the highest infection
rates where recently ranked number 14
the city of Albany itself was number
four in the world for coronavirus
infection rates and we have the seventh
slowest testing rate which means that we
don't know what is happening in Georgia
we do know that we have more deaths than
almost any other state in the southeast
and that we are not ready to return to
normal
what's even more concerning is that the
businesses that are opening are ones
like nail salons and restaurants places
where low income workers are going to be
compelled to go back to work in order to
keep their jobs and they're going to be
the most at risk for contracting the
disease and we have one of the weakest
health infrastructures in the country
without Medicaid expansion and one of
the highest rates of wrath' of hospital
closures in rural communities I was also
wondering Stacey how to use social
distance in a barber shop a nail salon
or a tattoo shop but your governor has
said this he knows that some of the
cases will go up he hold on for two
SEC's he said he knows the cases will go
up he said but the state is better
prepared to handle it and that he
doesn't give a damn about politics at
this particular time you think that's
true
this isn't about politics this is about
people's lives we have people who are
the most vulnerable and the least
resilient being put on the front lines
of contracting a disease that they
cannot get treatment for we have swathes
of Georgia where we have no hospitals no
doctors and no relief but we're also one
of the states that has the weakest
public infrastructure we have a hard
time getting unemployment benefits we
have a hard time getting access to death
to medical care there is no
legitimate reason for reopening the
state except for politics and I think
it's deeply disingenuous that he would
pretend otherwise
so what do you think it's gonna take to
get the testing right in Georgia it's
going to require funding but it's also
going to require recognizing that over
the last 20 years Republican leadership
has weakened the public health
infrastructure of our state and the
governor's refusal to expand Medicaid
means we haven't gotten the new
infusions of cash that could have helped
prepare us for this pandemic but the
reality is we are where we are and we
need to meet the cause and the challenge
where we are this is an issue of
competence this is not an issue of
politics and it is a question of
people's lives and putting the most
vulnerable on the frontlines to meet
some political goal is deeply
problematic let's talk about your new
initiative if we could move on it says
you will give $1,000 to 100,000
households how are you
selecting the people that will get the
money and where's the money coming from
so project 100 is a joint project
between give directly propel fresh EBT
stand for children these are three
organizations that work with the most
vulnerable Americans and the money is
coming from some incredible donors but
it's also coming from everyday people
who are willing to contribute effort at
project 100 us the people who will
receive the money our snap recipients
who use the propel fresh EBT app and
that's one of those social I'm sorry
it's an app that was designed to help
low income people better manage their
SNAP benefits we have two million users
who are receiving this who use this app
and they will be the frontline
recipients of these contributions